[Musica]
ormai sono di casa di ricordare marina e
tu sei preparata allora i cugini di
caltanissetta i cugini calabresi la
famiglia di trieste di tuo fratello
no non a luisa non la vita e poi le
cuginette alice clotilde allora mi sono
permessa di nuovo visto che edoardo mi
ha detto che vi è piaciuto molto il vino
che vi ho portato a natale mi ho presi
due così avete la scorta intima tu però
a natale non c'era la famiglia di nizza
è per i ventagli anche tutti i cugini
pensieri e allora cominciamo da lì alain
alone vinse e poi i cuginetti mi
piccolini che sono tali crigna e pensa
man come è facile ricordare poi l'altro
zio invece ha studiato la ragazza
algerina che teatret figliolini che sono
malika said ahmed ok mi studio per la
prossima volta che pone sotto questa sit
in i bene ora finalmente vi presento
lui un po precisiamo questi scioglie la
camicia piace lo stesso come lo facciamo
integrare il nostro gruppo chieti marina
cosa vi faccio da bere voi deve qualcosa
ma guardi visto che capodanno mi
andrebbe tantissimo vodka lemon e
limonata limonata il vento di dice mente
lama dove lei è liberata quinta e no
tipo per un cassetto decaffeinata guardi
il caffè intollerante al caffè a neve
niente il caffè devi ma è allora un tema
tigana tifato guardia di lana con la
passiflora che ho raccolto io questa
primavera va bene è buona va bene amore
eletti di questa quindi da un po più no
un portatore il vino relar l'aisla cg e
asciutto come ballerino e amore noi
siamo abituati a cose un po più patroni
l'ha anche lui e lui praticamente dove
sono room quindi facciamo così scegliamo
amore ancora a terra ben 33 punti bosca
treni tequila2 minimo di una diamo tutti
il compagno è tranquilla certo dopo
immaginiamo allora la scuola come da o
va bene non aveva finito da un po la
scuola non ho capito
l'ho finito da un po scolo non è lei sa
cosa fa e l'isola voi sì so sto cercando
di fare qualche stage cerco un po brava
mi raccomando che è importante è questo
a guadagnare laborando tu invece quali
solite i propositi per l'anno nuovo
dimmi un po e gli voglio andare a
ballare uscire fare le cose divertirmi
non ha bisogno di divertirsi qui poi
voglia tempo di divertiti adesso devi
lavorare studiare e mettere la testa a
posto che ballare non va bene ma non se
ne va portata in giro con te porta lame
e stanno intanto che questa qui la rete
un po che se ne sta andando per la
strada sbagliata
allora patrimonio costiero di
disinvestire quelle applicazioni per
comprare casa a sfruttare il boom
edilizio
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
auguri auguri ormai siamo cugini noti
auguri ciao cara auguri di buon anno
auguri
12 4
di tutto questo la guardia e non è che
questo 2 milioni giorno
[Musica]
aqualandia
ora facciamo crediamo ancora
vabbè puzzle abbia fatto scala quaranta
abbiamo fatta possiamo andare a letto e
volentieri si dai lati slanina della
nonna mi ha messo sig
buonanotte domani notte ci vediamo
domani mattina
ciao allora si è divertita a morire
amore ovvero bellissimo di martin eden
amore tira palla dobbiamo andare la
serata è stata bellissima se delle
grandi davvero però adesso senti un po
ma forse non ti sei accorto che qua noi
ti abbiamo accolto nel nostro gruppo
ora tu non te ne va da nessuna parte
anzi spesso lo bevi tutto fino
all'ultima goccia
butch forza tutta
[Musica]
giorno insomma si sia cambiata not
ermito così non potrei chiedere un
pigiama loro veramente ne avevamo solo
due si è compattato dire di no no grazie
amore preferisco mangiare fuori
ecco comunque che serata ieri e di un
botto anche se non come prima volta qui
non aveva buttato da parecchio di tutto
per tutta la città
ma chi ha creato io l'avevo trovato
dalla parte fatto la zia e io l'avevo
trovato che storia divertente dove siamo
noi i sassi palline ma ancora totale mai
mai mai hanno fidanzato mi ricordo che
lui ma noi siamo mamma
[Applauso]
con le altre fatto su libro ho bevuto
troppo meglio seppi di porto però è il
rese vian tutte le canzoni di sfere
basta perché prossimo capodanno vediamo
se basta vedere dobbiamo rinnovare e mi
raccomando ragazzi scrive the rich al
canale e mettetevi mi piace e commentate
facendo ci sta bene si è presidente il
capodanno con la fa con la famiglia
oppure con gli amici
meglio la famiglia ragazzi hanno un
bacio allevati badia di pagine
[Musica]